no se vislumbra un final para las
tensiones en Perú ya están en libertad
los casi 200 manifestantes llegados de
todo el país que se refugiaban en la
Universidad Nacional mayor de San Marcos
en Lima detenidos después de que un
contingente policial irrumpiera
violentamente las instalaciones el
sábado por la mañana algunos estudiantes
denunciaron agresiones físicas de las
fuerzas de seguridad
uso estas palabras No vas a salir de
aquí me golpeó con su palo y me tiró al
suelo y empezó a patearme
Y es que las protestas que exigen la
renuncia de la presidenta Dina boluarte
continúan en la capital y el sur de Perú
con los manifestantes acusando a las
autoridades de criminalizar El estallido
social que deja miles de heridos y más
de 50 muertos directos en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad incluido un policía y otros
nueve fallecidos por los bloqueos de las
últimas semanas las autoridades locales
por su parte justificaron el
allanamiento al campus universitario
Pues a las denuncias de los organismos
humanitarios internacionales que uso
excesivo de la fuerza podemos informar
que la policía ingresó por actos de
flagrancia por la presunta comisión de
dos hechos haber ingresado al predio
universitario sin autorización Y en
segundo lugar por haber supuestamente
sustraído algunos aparatos electrónicos
de la universidad
este lunes al Primer Ministro peruano
Alberto tarola declaró ante la fiscalía
por las muertes sucedidas durante las
protestas acusado de posible genocidio
homicidio calificado y lesiones graves
Mientras tanto sindicatos y
organizadores de las manifestaciones
preparan una segunda gran marcha de la
toma de Lima para este martes